I just want to do a quick video to
remind you about something I said a year
ago about the game Stargate time keepers
I'm really really hot and I've got to go
shopping
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV
movie channel
[Music]
just over a year ago we were expecting
the Stargate game timekeepers to come
out but I told you that Amazon were very
very keen for that game to tie into the
bigger franchise that they wanted
Stargate to be a multi-platform
franchise TV shows cinematic movies
which it now looks like we're going to
be getting and games now I think there's
going to be comic books etc etc as well
but
the game was delayed for over a year
there's been absolute silence on whether
it was going to be coming out or not why
was that because Amazon intentionally
wanted it to be paused until they were
ready to announce the bigger franchise
now game developers of Stargate
timekeepers are saying that the game is
going to be released in July now what
other thing did we think might get
announced in July
oh yeah the intention of Amazon to
actually start working on the Stargate
franchise so this is just one more
indication that varying very possibly
Stargate is going to be announced in
July at San Diego Comic-Con
I'm getting quite excited by this and
this game by the way it jumps through
time and things are supposed to go
through multiple time periods and
different parts of the Stargate wider
universe
I was told well over a year ago Amazon
saw this really has a brilliant
opportunity to remind people about
Stargate to bring a younger generation
potentially Gamers into the Stargate
franchise and really it's just a
brilliant way of advertising the bigger
franchise that was going to follow
this could be very very interesting
so anybody out there that is actually a
gamer wants to play this game let me
know because I'd love to know what it's
like
to be honest I'm too damn busy but maybe
we'll get Matt to do it anyway
if you are new to the channel don't
forget to like subscribe hit the Bell
notification you know what to do I try
to get these videos out to you as quick
as I can let's look forward to the game
but more importantly let's look forward
to San Diego Comic-Con
foreign
[Music]